alternative financial services better
known as payday lenders and check
cashers are both popular with consumers
and a frequent target of journalists and
comedians it's the cool objects under
screws also but those paycheck advances
can carry high interest rates that may
hurt more than they help to learn how
these businesses operate
Lisa Servan took a break from teaching
at the University of Pennsylvania to
work as a teller in the South Bronx and
in Oakland California I spoke with her
about the unbanked of America how the
new middle-class survives serve ons
first-hand account of what may be the
most widely misunderstood industry in
America so the first thing that really
struck me in the book is that there are
more payday lenders and check cashers in
the United States than McDonald's and
Starbucks combined is that true yes
that's actually just payday lenders
right not even counting the check
cashers and that's an important
difference because in 13 States payday
lending is illegal so that speaks to
some incredible need for this what you
call alternative banking service exactly
exactly in particularly in the case of
payday lenders for short-term credit
small amounts of money for a small
amount of time what gave you the idea to
sort of take a break from your Ivy
League job and work in of all places in
the South Bronx I was interested in why
so many people were using alternative
financial services payday lenders check
cashers pawnshops when the story about
them that you hear in the press and even
from consumer advocates and from policy
makers is that they're predatory they're
taking advantage of poor people and yet
in the early 90s you started to see an
upward trajectory of use these
businesses growing an incredible amount
so payday lending grew from a ten
billion dollar business to a thirty
billion dollar business in about ten
years in the early 2000s and the kind of
the implicit message in all of that
writing was that low-income people who
were presumed to be the primary users I
found out that wasn't exactly true
either were somehow making bad decisions
that they weren't informed enough and if
only they had the information that you
know wealthier upper-middle class people
had then they would choose differently
that's the whole implicit message even
in the FDIC's
categorization of people is banked
unbanked under bags and by looking at
the numbers I couldn't really figure it
out I knew from working in poor
communities for 20 years that low-income
people know where their money goes
probably more than people who have more
of a buffer and I realized that if I
wanted to really understand it I had to
get as close to the problem as possible
you know when you're a researcher you
you have to match the method to the
question and the only method I could
really figure out was to get really
close and I knew that even just talking
to people in interviewing them would not
give me the full story and it turned out
to be right really by working behind the
window for months and looking at the way
that people manage their money I learned
a ton these check cashers are often
targets of journalists and academics as
people who do or organizations that do
prey on sort of poor minority clients
did you go into that with Intuit with
that expectation because that's the sort
of the dominant narrative that's out
there it's certainly what I what I
thought before I began to look into it
more deeply so kind of a pivotal moment
for me was having this man Joe Coleman
who runs a chain of check cashers in the
South Bronx and Harlem come to a class I
was teaching in at the moment that he
walked in the door my students and I all
thought exactly what you said you know
these are bad guys now one of them is
coming to our class we get to really
like ask him the tough questions and Joe
came in and he made a very compelling
argument for why he felt like his
businesses that were serving people in
those communities the way they needed to
be served and that banks were not doing
that and banks didn't really want their
business and so that kind of made me
think maybe there's more to this story
and so I tried to go in with a really
open mind once I once I went to both of
those businesses and worked at them and
so you worked as a clerk yeah behind the
counter you weren't undercover no I
wasn't undercover that seemed like it
would be an unethical to try to pretend
to be somebody I wasn't I sort of so it
made for a little bit of awkwardness and
that the neighborhood I was working in
in the South Bronx is a primarily Latino
neighborhood I'm not a Latina women who
I worked with were younger than me
Spanish is not my first language
although I speak it but you know we
overcame that pretty quickly when you're
standing behind a counter you're working
with people
a common project people in line need
something and if you can provide it for
them it kind of works out what was the
first thing that you discovered when you
were working there I think the very
first thing I discovered was how service
oriented the businesses were after I did
my stint as a teller I came out from
behind the counter and I talked I did
interviews with people and the three
things they told me that were the
reasons why they chose to check casher
were cost which was incredibly
surprising that it was cheaper than
using a bank
transparency they felt like they knew
exactly what they were getting and how
much they were paying and service which
I already mentioned so basically really
old-fashioned values exactly exactly
take me through some of the people who
go there because some of them are really
fascinated yeah so for instance Carlos
is one of the really fascinating
characters in your book who is Carlos
Carlos is a small business person he
does he's a small contractor he does you
know carpentry and painting and
sheetrocking and all that kind of stuff
he would come into the check casher
regularly to cash a check that he got
from from a client and you know I saw
him come and go and then one day he
brought in what I thought was a rather
large check it was about $5,000 he puts
it under the window under the slot and I
cashed it and the fee for cashing that
check so they differ around the
countries from state to state but in New
York City at that point was one point
nine five percent of the face value of
the check so it was almost $200 you know
I'm kind of looking at that money or
looking at what I gave back to Carlos
and saying like that's that's real money
right like he could I don't know you
could save for his kid's education he
could take his wife out to dinner he
could put in a retirement account all of
the kinds of things that people are
saying when they're saying check cashers
are expensive so Carlos leaves and I
asked the teller who trained me this was
really one of the benefits of not being
undercover you know I'm saying like why
is he doing that he's gotta have a bank
account and she said well you know it's
Thursday so probably he's paying us guys
tomorrow you know and if you're in any
city and probably not just city's a lot
of workers are maybe undocumented or
and/or don't have a bank account and so
you'll see these contractors going
around and paying them
cash well if Carla's deposited that
check on Thursday in his bank he
wouldn't have the cash until Tuesday or
Wednesday and that that time was the
banks are getting what's called the
float it's huge for people that are
living very close to the edge so he
needed his money right away and he was
willing to pay for it another reason why
he may have done that is that he got a
job where he needed paint supplies
materials to start so that if he
couldn't have started the next day he
wouldn't have gotten to work so again
he's paying for access to his own money
right away you do address this idea that
people take out Lo and it become sort of
addictive they take out loans they need
to take out another loan to pay back the
previous loan and they get sort of stuck
in this sort of endless cycle and that's
sort of a reason that people have said
no they to close down a lot of these
banks payday lenders a lot of these
payday lenders right right payday loans
in case people don't know what they are
they're small short-term loans ranging
from say fifty to three hundred dollars
usually that happen to carry fees so the
place that I worked
check-check Center in Oakland California
you would pay you'd have to pay 15
dollars per hundred dollars borrowed
that adds up to a pretty hefty amount of
money right the way they're designed the
reason they're called payday loans is
that they're due on the next day that
the person gets a check whether it's
their paycheck or a government check and
that's usually were paid either by
monthly or monthly what happens is that
a lot of the time the people the reason
somebody comes and gets that loan is
that they've had an expense that they
didn't expect maybe a medical bill a car
repair they need the money right away to
deal with the problem and sometimes the
consequences are dire right if I don't
fix my car then I can't get to work and
I'll lose my job
the problem becomes when it's two weeks
later and you haven't had an income
bonus you haven't had a to pay for that
loan and so what happens is that people
roll it over and they continue to borrow
that hundred dollars but they pay
another fifteen dollar fee and so if
people continue to do that then they're
paying much more than than they
originally borrowed and that's where
that's where people get troubled and
critics of this exact scenario they look
at this and they say this is why
lenders need to be either regulated or
shut down entirely and they're bad in
what several states yeah yeah six eight
seven thirteen states thirteen states
but you have a very different take on it
and I think very rightly you say that
that shutting down payday lenders like
that doesn't eliminate the underlying
problem which is the need the basic need
and the basic demand for these services
that's right
I think if you got rid of every payday
lender on the planet you'd still have
this need right and people needing to
get them back I mean some of this spills
over from financial issues into Jersey
or basic poverty issues exactly exactly
and if we're not paying attention to
that problem also you know no matter
what we do in the financial services
industry and we need to do a lot don't
get me wrong but it's not going to solve
that problem
you paint a very sort of darkly
pessimistic view of the American economy
frankly in the beginning and makes sense
given than some of the locations you
were working in but you switch very
quickly to the innovators reaction to
what it seems like a very rosy picture
for the future which is based in apps
and technology and people really trying
to shake up the way the whole network of
finance works in a very deep way
can you talk about that and how that
sort of gives us a much better outlook
for the city for sure yeah the good news
is that one two things one is that we
don't have to just look to banks for
solutions to the financial services
problem I don't think we should let
banks off the hook but we don't have to
look only to them and so we have two
kinds of people in the innovative space
one are people who I think are doing
really interesting work on the
infrastructure of banking so two that I
really think are doing terrific work one
is called ripple in San Francisco and
ripple is creating what it calls an
Internet of value making it easy to move
your money without cost and immediately
the same way that we move information
using email on the Internet and so what
that would do is that when you cash and
when Carlos goes to the bag and puts his
check in the money would be a mail
available to him immediately if somebody
is sending money to their relatives in
Mexico or Guatemala instead of having it
stopped five times between Western Union
and the bank in Mexico City it would
move immediately and free and cheaply
without cost at
bottom though I think what these apps do
and I think what you mentioned later on
your book is ultimately about the
question of do we trust individuals to
make decisions with their own finance
even if they're poor even if they're in
desperate circumstances and I think you
talk about that you talk about talk
about a little bit about that ultimately
we have to respect people's judgment and
without judging them and without judging
their choices I think there's a lot of
judgment in even you know I mentioned
before this way that we think about
people now is in terms of whether
they're begg'd unbanked or underbanked
right and I think that that was a useful
framework for talking about people for a
long time but there's a sort of an edge
of being derogatory in that and kind of
if you're unbanked then there's
something wrong with you it assumes that
banking is the one and the best and only
way to manage your finances and that
people who don't do that are somehow
deficient in some way so we need to
unpack this whole category of subprime
people or unbanked people and look at
the specific populations within those
larger categories so the old idea of the
rite of passage of your first bank
account at Pulaski Bank is that dead is
that something in the past my kids don't
have bank accounts at pulaski i recently
opened them bank accounts at the bank i
go to now
but but yeah i think it's a little bit
it's a little bit different now we have
to teach them the habits of spending and
saving and being able to give money away
if they're fortunate enough to have more
money than they need to do some charity
work but but yeah i think i think it's a
very different world now that was a
hallmark of middle-class life right
right you've got a bank account
welcome to memory that's right that's
right I know people who still have those
passed books that they save from when
they were kids
ya know I remember and I remember not
being able to get money out of the bank
after 3 p.m.
that's right yeah and we organized our
life that way it's not that way anymore
well thanks a lot for talking to us
thank you so much thanks for having me
for a recent TV I'm Todd crane
you